Wow err sudden shutdown stranded
thousands of passengers in North America
and Europe the Iceland based airline is
one of at least eight budget airlines in
seven months to cease operations many
wild travellers were already at the
airport when they learned their airline
was no longer flying yikes we rushed the
airport and now we're trying to figure
out how to get home I don't think that
they went bankrupt
this had to be a time coming so you knew
that it was a possibility when I flew
over here a few days ago that you might
not be able to take my return trip they
had put me in a hotel and then the hotel
kicked me out I was boarding my flight
and it said hey your connecting flight
is cancelled we are very sorry and I
couldn't believe it
hopefully I get my money back and I'm
hoping at least I don't really want to
waste $700 for nothing I'll say Brian
Kelly is a founder and CEO of you know
the points guy a website and media brand
that offers advice on air travel he
joins us at the table hey Brian thanks
Raph though we're glad you here in
January there was an article that said
'wow is out wide wowed itself $49
one-way tickets from the u.s. to five
European cities so you think if it's
it's what your mom and dad used to say
if it's too good to be true it is yes
unfortunately you know Wow came into
market several years ago you know even
$99 fares to Europe really opened up the
market for a lot of people and they were
doing okay for a long time okay
typically you have the kind of
introductory rate and then the prices
start ups are worth billions of dollars
yet lose money every year it's the same
with Airlines they were trying to build
critical mass with people trusting the
airline everything is about psychology
with Airlines and so they were trying to
break into a market take customers away
from the main carriers the problem is
you know once your credit runs up in the
airline business you need a lot of cash
to run Airlines so if you don't have you
know that line of credit which happened
this week I mean they started taking the
planes away right away the point of the
woman that NATO who got stranded and she
said they they probably knew it was
gonna happen why did they let me fly
yeah yeah you know well everything you
know they had a prayer that more funding
would come in it was about two there was
actually a US hedge fund that was about
to invest which would have kept things
going it just at the very last minute
didn't so now thousands of people are
stranded
what do you do the first thing you do
yes I'm now in Paris with no way now in
Paris with no way home so a lot of
airlines are offering rescue fares so
the problem with these rescue fares is
all the flights out of especially
Reykjavik or full 96 days and you've got
to pay out of your own pocket the
airlines not paying for anything the
airline is no longer and then you call
your credit card company yes the very
best tip I have for people is your
credit card should be able to assist
certain credit cards give you trip in
your interruption and cancellation
insurance and that's why it's critical
when you buy airfare use a credit card
that offers that some that have no
annual fees will cover up to ten
thousand dollars so you're not only
gonna get your ticket price back but
they're also going to cover that hotel
for five nights
so people who book using the right card
can just you know buy a new ticket out
and then just reimburse it later on I
like the guy who said I showed up for my
flight and the not the flight was
canceled the airline yes and we've heard
about quite a few cancellations of
budget airlines in recent months you
know where do you stand on them going
forward would you buy a budget ticket I
you know I would you know there's none
right now I think I'm 67 so I generally
don't fly budgets but um but for people
who aren't 6-7 they what I would buy a
ticket but I would use a credit card
that offers protection that's great and
if you don't have a credit card that
offers protection bike trip insurance
because you know you are taking a risk
not from the airline but not from the
airline so the airlines offer trip
protection and whenever they make it
really easy to tack on at the end that's
not your best policy getting an
independent policy backed by a huge
insure so you have peace of mind so I
would hedge your bets a little bit if
you're gonna go really cheap make sure
you've got the protection buy two seats
and you can stretch out even if you're
six seven whatever it's all on me Brian
thank you very much appreciate it